so I stand before you as a as an
evolutionary biologist a professor of
evolutionary biology which sounds like a
rather fancy title if I may say so
myself and I'm gonna talk about two
topics that aren't normally talked about
together and that's market economies and
fungi or is it fungi or as we say in
Europe now funghi you know there's still
no consensus on how to say this word so
I want you to imagine a market economy
that's 400 million years old one that's
so ubiquitous that it operates in almost
every ecosystem of the world so huge
that can connect millions of traders
simultaneously and so persistent that it
survived mass extinctions it's here
right now under our feet you just can't
see it and unlike human economies that
rely on cognition to make decisions
traders in this market they beg borrow
steal cheats all in the absence of
thought so hidden from our eyes plant
roots are colonized by a fungus called
Arbus killer mycorrhizae now the fungus
forms these complex networks underground
the fine filaments thinner than even
threads of cotton so follow one of these
fungi and it connects multiple plants
simultaneously you can think of it as an
underground subway system where each
root is a station where resources are
loaded and unloaded and it's also very
dense so roughly the length of many
meters even a kilometer in a single gram
of dirt so that's the length of 10
football fields in just a thimble full
of soil and it's everywhere so if you
pass
over a tree a shrub a vine even a tiny
weed you passed over a micro eyes'll
Network roughly 80% of all plant species
are associated with these mycorrhizae
fungi so what does a root covered in
fungi have to do with our global economy
and why is an evolutionary biologist
have I spent the last 10 years of my
life learning economic jargon well the
first thing you need to understand is
that trade deals made by plant and
fungal partners are surprisingly similar
to those made by us but perhaps even
more strategic you see plant and fungal
partners they're not exchanging stocks
and bonds they're exchanging essential
resources and for the fungus that sugars
and fats gets all of its carbon directly
from the plant partner so much carbon so
every year roughly 5 billion tons of
carbon from plants go into this network
underground for the roots what they need
is phosphorus and nitrogen so by
exchanging their carbon they get access
to all of the nutrients collected by
that fungal Network so to make the trade
the fungus penetrates into the root cell
of the host and forms a tiny structure
called an arbor School which is Latin
for a little tree now you can think of
this as the physical stock exchange of
the trade market so up until now it
seems very harmonious right I scratch
your back you scratch mine both partners
get what they need but here is where we
need to pause and understand the power
of evolution and natural selection you
see there's no room for amateur traders
on this market making the right trade
strategy determines who lives and who
dies now I use the word strategy
but of course plants have fungi they
don't have brains they're making these
exchanges in the absence of anything
that we would consider as thought but as
scientists we use behavioral terms such
as strategy to describe behaviors to
certain conditions actions and reactions
that are actually programmed into the
DNA of the organism so I started
studying these trade strategies when I
was 19 years old and I was living in the
tropical rainforest of Panama now
everybody at the time was interested in
this incredible diversity above-ground
in the hyper diversity right these are
tropical rainforests but I was
interested in the complexity below
ground we knew that the networks existed
and we knew they were important and I'm
gonna say it again by important I mean
important so the basis of all plant
nutrition for all the diversity that you
do see above-ground but at the time we
didn't know how these networks worked we
didn't know how they functioned why did
only certain plants interact with
certain fungi so fast forward to when I
started my own group and we really began
to play with this trade market you see
we would manipulate conditions we would
create a good trading partner by growing
a plant in the Sun and a poor trading
partner by growing it in the shade we
would then connect these with a fungal
Network and we found that the fungi were
consistently good at discriminating
among good and bad trading partners they
would allocate more resources to the
host plant giving them more carbon now
we would run the reciprocal experiments
where we would inoculate a host plant
with good and bad fungi and they were
all so good at discriminating between
these trade partners so what you have
there is the perfect conditions for a
market to emerge it's a simple market
but it's a market nonetheless
we're the better trading partner is
consistently favored but is it a fair
market now this is where you need to
understand that like humans plants and
fungi are incredibly opportunistic
there's evidence that the fungus once it
penetrates into the plant cell it can
actually hijack the plants own nutrient
uptake system it does this by
suppressing the plants own ability to
take up nutrients from the soil so this
creates a dependency of the plant on the
fungus it's a it's a false addiction of
sorts whereby the plant has to feed the
fungus just to get access to the
resources right around its own root
there's also evidence that the fungi are
good at inflating the price of nutrients
they do this by extracting the nutrients
from the soil but then rather than
trading them with a host they hoard them
in their network so this makes them
unavailable to the plant and other
competing fungi so basic economics as
resource availability goes down the
value goes up the plant is forced to pay
more for the same amount of resources
but it's not all in favor of the fungus
plants can be extremely cunning as well
there are some orchids and I always
think of orchids somehow seem like the
most devious of the plant species in the
world and there are some orchids that
just tap directly into the network and
steal all their carbon so these orchids
they don't even make green leaves to
photosynthesize they're just white
so rather than photosynthesizing tap
into the network steal the carbon and
give nothing in return now I think it's
fair to say that these types of
parasites also flourished in our human
markets so as we begin to decode these
strategies we learn some lessons and the
first one was that there's no altruism
in this system there's no trade favors
right we don't see strong evidence of
the fungus helping dying or struggling
plants unless it's directly in favor
directly benefits the fungus itself now
I'm not saying if this is good or bad
right unlike humans a fungus of course
cannot judge its own morality and it's a
biologist I'm not advocating for these
types of ruthless neoliberal market
dynamics enacted by the fungi but the
trade system it provides us with a
benchmark to study what an economy looks
like when it's been shaped by natural
selection for hundreds of millions of
years in the absence of morality when
strategies are just based on the
gathering and processing of information
uncontaminated by cognition no jealousy
no spite but no hope no joy so we've
made progress in decoding the most basic
trade principles at this point but as
scientists we always want to take it one
step further and we're interested in
more complex economic dilemmas and
specifically we're interested in the
effects of inequality so inequality has
really become a defining feature of
today's economic landscape but the
challenges of inequality not unique to
the human world I think it's humans we
tend to think that everything is unique
to us but organisms in nature must face
of relentless variation in their access
to resources how does a fungus that can
again be meters long change its trade
strategy when it's exposed
simultaneously to a rich patch in a poor
patch and more generally how do
organisms in nature how do they use
trade to their advance
which when they're faced with
uncertainty in terms of their access to
resources here's what I have to let you
in on a secret
studying trade underground is incredibly
difficult you can't see where or when
important trade deals take place so our
group helped pioneer a method a
technology whereby we could tag
nutrients with nanoparticles fluorescing
nanoparticles called quantum dots what
the quantum dots allow us to do is
actually light up the nutrients so we
can visually track their movements
across the fungal Network and into the
hosts route so this allows us finally to
see the unseen so we can study how fungi
bargain at a small scale with their
plant hosts so to study inequality we
exposed a fungal Network to this varying
concentrations of fluorescing phosphorus
mimicking patches of abundance and
scarcity across this artificial
landscape we then carefully quantified
fungal trade and we found two things the
first thing we found was that inequality
encouraged the fungus to trade more so I
can use the word encouraged or
stimulated or forced but the bottom line
is that compared to control conditions
inequality was associated with higher
levels of trade this is important
because it suggests that evolving a
trade partnership in nature can help
organisms cope with the uncertainty of
accessing resources second we found the
exposure to inequality the fungus would
move resources from the rich patch of
the network actively transport them to
the poor side of the network now of
course we could see this because the
patches were fluorescing in different
colors so at first this result was
incredibly
sling was it to help the poor side of
the network no we found that the fungus
gained more by first moving the
resources to where demand was higher
simply by changing where across the
network the fungus was trading it could
manipulate the value of those resources
now this stimulated us to really dig
deeper into how information is shared it
suggests a high level of sophistication
or at least a medium level of
sophistication in an organism with no
cognition how is it that a fungus can
sense market conditions across its
network and then make calculations of
where and when to trade so we wanted to
look about information and how its
shared across this network how the
fungus integrates cues so to do that
what you need to do is dive deep in and
get a higher resolution into the network
itself we began to study complex flows
inside the - network so what you're
looking at right now is the living
fungal Network with the cellular
contents moving across it this is
happening in real time so you can see
the timestamp up there so this is
happening right this video isn't sped up
this is what is happening under our feet
right now and there's a couple of things
that I want you to notice it speeds up
it slows down it switches directions so
we're working now with biophysicists to
try to dissect this complexity how is
the fungus using these complex flow
patterns to share and process
information and make these trade
decisions our fungi better at making
trade calculations than us now here's
where you can potentially borrow models
from nature we're increasingly reliant
on computer algorithms to make us
profitable trades and split-second time
scales but computer algorithms
and fungi they both operate in similar
uncocked avais the fungi just happens to
be a living machine what would happen if
we compare and compete the trading
strategies of these two who would win
the tiny capitalist that's been around
since before and the fall of the
dinosaurs my money is on the fungus
thank you
[Applause]